et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
boris valoran jours si beaucoup d'être
avec nouveauté mais j'en porte parole du
parti socialiste
si vous êtes auteur de ce livre un
esprit de résistance c'est chez
flammarion on va en parler tout à
l'heure en étant 100 pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représentée par stéphane bern et pour
l'encéphale bonjour stéphane qui dirige
le bureau parisien du journal ouest
france
on commence par le climat boris sallaud
le texte le sénat examinera cet après
midi le texte sur un éventuel référendum
climat le projet de loi
constitutionnelle le sénat n'est pas
d'accord avec l'assemblée hier vous avez
sans doute vu cette une du journal du
dimanche sur un référendum qui serait
enterré ce qu emmanuel macron a démenti
dans l'après midi à strasbourg en disant
qu'il faut laisser travailler le
parlement est ce que vous croyez encore
qu'un référendum aura lieu
écoutez je crois qu'il est souhaitable
je crois que la cause est suffisamment
importante pour que tout soit mis en
oeuvre pour j'allais dire construire le
conte premier républicain qui transcende
les familles politiques et qui est comme
seul objet la préservation de notre
environnement dans un moment très grave
de déséquilibres environnementaux et
climatiques
donc oui j'ai comme voulu la une d'un
journal généralement bien informé quand
il s'agit ce qui se passe dans le
gouvernement et qui n'était pas
rassurant et qui semblaient tirés par
anticipation les conclusions des débats
parlementaires qui n'est pas achevée est
ce que je m'étonne de la méthode temps
j'ai le sentiment qu'en réalité
l'exécutif tient le débat parlementaire
pour un exercice de style
non mais il faut aller au bout il faut
comme nous l'avons fait nous socialistes
à l'assemblée nationale eh bien le
défendre un texte défendent des
propositions qui vont dans le sens de
celles du gouvernement les sénateurs
socialistes le font ici et je crois que
il faut attendre de voir où nous en
sommes mais je voudrais aller à
l'assemblée vous avez voté vous la
version du trophée un élément est ce que
vous êtes prêts à un compromis avec la
version du sénat où ce référendum il
doit faire mieux sur la version du
gouvernement d'écoutés genou que je ne
connais pas encore la version qui
sortira du sénat vous avez vu celle qui
est sortie de la commission et enlever
mon père m'en tire qui fait référence
est en tête en effet en retrait il faut
continuer de travailler de convaincre je
crois qu'il faut aller à un référendum
si cela doit améliorer le cadre
juridique dans lequel nous allons
ensuite légiférer je crois que tous
préfèrent la version compter sur la
version la plus ambitieuse possible donc
vous êtes prêt à faire un compromis
auxquels il faut il faut regarder où ce
qui sort exactement du sénat est ce
qu'on peut imaginer que l'elysée que
présent réduit choisissent une autre
voie pour réformer la constitution et
l'article 1er écoutez ans notamment la
réunion d'un du coût du congrès à
l'automne ça c'est l'envisagera écoutez
je ne sais pas quelles sont ses
intentions
je me souviens que le général de gaulle
faisait aussi des référendums vous savez
qu'il n'était pas tout à fait dans la
lettre de la constitution et il allait
néanmoins normand au bout à telle
enseigne qu'un certain nombre de
constitutionnalistes y ont vu une autre
voie une forme de conventions de la
constitution qui se seraient institués
par là par la pratique une autre voie
pour réformer la mêlée si j'obtenais par
exemple la réforme de l'article 1er de
la constitution sans passer par un
référendum ou pensais qu'ils auraient
une déception notamment de toutes les
personnes qui ont suivi et soutenu la
convention citoyenne pour le climat le
souhait le souhaite évidemment l'un des
hommes parce que le sentiment de
beaucoup et je crois que c'est le nôtre
c'est que évidemment la mobilisation de
la population est importante que le
soutien aux fonds du peuples
constituants dans une affaire aussi
importante et bien être un signal très
fort très positif d'engagement en faveur
de la question environnementale
mais enfin si cette voie est bloqué il
faudra sans doute envisager une autre
on entend beaucoup dans la majorité
présidentielle un rejet sur la droite
sénatoriale c'est la faute de la droite
sénatoriale ci sera faire un dogme n'a
pas lieu s'il n'a pas lu est ce que vous
partagez cette analyse
ou est ce que vous y voyez
une manière pour la majorité
présidentielle de se défausser sur ces
questions d'écologie
écoutez le plus à droite sénatoriale ne
soutiennent pas la proposition du
gouvernement je crois que chacun ont
fait le constat est ce qu'on peut le
regretter
oui je peux vous dire que nous
socialistes dès la première proposition
de réforme institutionnelle proposée au
parlement par le président de la
république nous avions fait cette
proposition de réécriture de l'article 1
de la constitution dans ce sens a eu
d'autres rédactions bon c'est pas voilà
c est proposée par le gouvernement n'est
pas tout à fait la nôtre mais voilà
ensuite c'est toujours la faute de
quelqu'un d'autre pour le gouvernement
c'est la faute des parlementaires c'est
la fois des partenaires sociaux c'est la
faute de l'état profond pour reprendre
l'expression du président de la
république
enfin c'est toujours la faute de
quelques de quelqu'un d'autre et bien
voilà il faut jamais renoncer à
convaincre sur des sujets importants
c'est d'autant plus nécessaire on va
parler d'un autre sujet d'actualité ça
concerne les policiers stéphane qu il ya
eu un rassemblement hier à avignon et
jean castex reçoit les représentants des
syndicats de police à matignon ce soir
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que le premier
ministre le donner comme nouvelle
garantie ou com qu'est-ce qui peut qu
est ce qui peut faire par rapport à par
rapport au drame que les polices ils
viennent de vivre d'abord dire que ce
drame ait été effroyable et nous
rappelle que être policier être gendarme
et bien c'est prendre des risques au
péril de sa vie pour protéger notre
sécurité publique et dans le
rassemblement qui a eu hier en avignon
ça a constaté qu'il y avait beaucoup de
citoyens d'usagé de de la police qui
sont venus en soutien et c'est important
aussi que la police sentent que les
citoyens vol de cette protection de
cette police républicaine
le fait qu'ils soient reçus aujourd'hui
par le premier ministre est aussi un
acte important il ne faut pas le faire
seulement à l'occasion du drame aussi
terrible soit il il faut le faire de
façon continue et ce que le premier
ministre leur dire c'est déjà leur dire
quelle est la politique pénale du
gouvernement - clés pour vous bah oui
c'est à dire que j'ai à dire
la diligence des poursuites et
diligences des condamnations la
diligence dans l'exécution des peines
que le sentiment soit très clair que
assassiner quelqu'un ça n'est jamais
anodin et que quand on assassine un
policier et bien il y à une violence
d'autant plus insupportable je crois que
c'est important et puis ensuite va sans
doute se poseront des questions sur la
sécurisation des interventions les
méthodes d'interpellation de patrouille
âge peut-être sont décidément forcément
des pannes spécifique quand on s'attaque
aux forces de l'ordre pour mme
appliquons déjà avec toute la rigueur
celles qui sont ce qu'ils sont ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
écoutez pas suffi pour nous faire il
faut le faire il faut le dire il faut le
faire savoir et puis ensuite la question
de la façon dont les policiers
interviennent le rééquipement tous ces
sujets là doivent être mis sur la table
en étant évidemment à l'écouté de ceux
qui sont sur le terrain mais ils sont
mis sur la table c'est l'objet du bureau
de la sécurité qui se tient ces
dernières semaines là il a été bien sûr
derrière mais vous savez vous avez
compris que les chercheuses belle le
beau vol ce qui est important c'est pas
tant la méthode que le point de sortie
goûter attendons de voir ce qui va se
passer nous mêmes vous savez qu'on a
participé à des commissions d'enquêté
parlementaires qui ont nourri ce débat
là tant mieux c'est un sujet qui est un
sujet éminemment importante et dans
l'eure de préoccupation des français on
le sait la question de la sécurité est
importante
alors c'est une préoccupation majeure
chez les françaises qu est ce que c est
ce que la gauche s'empare pleinement de
ce sujet aujourd'hui où ce que ça reste
un sujet difficile à traiter pour vous
mais en quoi est ce un sujet difficile à
traiter dépasser une certaine à une
certaine époque
vous avez rattrapé le retard époque car
les époques changent vous savez ce qu'a
été le dernier quinquennat
du point de vue de la sécurité avec des
attentats dont vous avez le souvenir
douloureux
il ya eu une mobilisation il ya eu des
recrutements importants
une organisation de du renseignement
beaucoup plus performante
il ya eu des achats de matériel
d'équipement le renforcement de la
formation
y'a pas de naïveté sur ce sujet là après
il ya une politique pénale qui est une
politique pénale plus de droits d'une
politique pénale qui est de gauche
il y à des doctrines interventions qui
peuvent continuer d'être est d'être
interrogé et voilà nous prenons notre
pas dans ses réflexions là j'allais dire
de façon responsable et dans la
conformité à ce que à ce que nous sommes
votre actualité c'est cette nouvelle
tribune des militaires qui a été publié
ces dernières heures par valeurs
actuelles des militaires d'activé cette
fois tribune qui vient en soutien à
celles précédemment publiés alors les
militaires ils répondent à la critique a
été faite que les militaires ne doivent
pas parler que ce n'est pas le rôle de
ils disent c'est à nous de dire ça nous
sommes apolitiques et nous livrons un
constat professionnel et je vais vous
citer une des phrases évidemment les
longues cette tribune nous voyons le
communautarisme s'installer dans
l'espace public nous voyons la haine de
la france et de son histoire devenir la
norme
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je pense
que une armée républicaine est au
service des gouvernements élus
démocratiquement
voilà et que l'expression des politiques
des françaises et des français sur ce
sujet est souveraine et que la question
de la cohésion nationale la question de
la sécurité
la question toutes ces questions là
elles sont soit talent est sûre et sur
le débat est donc il faut que chacun
soit dans son rôle
et moi je plaide pour une armée
républicaine respectueuse des
institutions de la république et qui ne
laisse pas sous-entendre que elle
pourrait j'allais dire intervenir dans
quel cadre
c'est le cadre républicain c'est le seul
que je connaisse c'est votre
interprétation de ce genre de tribus sur
ce genre de tribunes ça vous intéresse
elle est plutôt inquiétante
quand j'entends une façon de
l'expression femise est un sacrement
chose ce n'est pas rassurant
cette fois ça rassurant et en même temps
je connais beaucoup de militaires
d'activé parfaitement républicain
parfaitement dans leurs responsabilités
assumant directement l'émission assumant
l'édition cette tribu des nuls si ça ne
signe pas je ne sais pas qui c'est mais
moi je peux vous dire que beaucoup je
dis je dis qu'il faut c'est pas par
hasard si ce n'est pas assigné qu'ils
disent qu'ils sont et en tout cas vous
avez bien compris que je suis attachée à
une armée républicaine au service de la
république nous service aussi de la paix
civile qui est la seule façon de vivre
ensemble
et donc voilà c'est aux représentants du
peuple tous les échelons de la nation
d'être les garants de cela la tribune
précédentes étaient portés par des
militaires qui n'étaient plus des
militaires d'activé cette fois ci ce
sont des ce sont des jeux ne sont pas si
son choix je ne sais pas qui c'est mais
qu'est ce que je vais secrète à majeures
peuvent rester dans une logique de
sanction à l'égard des signataires côté
on va voir comment le gouvernement veut
réagir mais vous vous avez bien noté que
cet anonyme je le dis chacun doit être à
sa place et dans ses responsabilités et
sur le fond de ce qu'ils disent mais sur
le fond c'est écoutez vous savez c'est
une allée dire c'est un vocabulaire bien
connu ça n'est pas tout à fait un hasard
si c'est publié dans valeurs actuelles
voilà cent mais au fond les lignes c'est
pas la mienne on va parler de la crise
sanitaire puisque les députés examinent
cette après midi le texte sur la gestion
de la sortie de la crise sanitaire alors
il prévoit notamment ce texte un régime
transitoire de sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire sortie au 1er juin
régime transitoire jusqu'au 31 octobre
est ce que c'est une méthode que vous
voterez alors d'abord vous dire que
cette transition elle est
particulièrement du 31 octobre et
il ya la possibilité d'ailleurs de
proroger cette période de transition
sans repasser devant forcément devant le
parlement c'est une longue éclipse du
débat démocratique et ça pose une
difficulté oui je crois que la
démocratie et le débat parlementaire
n'est jamais un inconvénient pour
affronter ces situations difficiles donc
oui je le demande ensuite il ya la
question vous l'avez évoqué cette
transition il est important d'envisager
la sortie de l'état violon solitaire il
ya notamment la question du pass
sanitaire il ya beaucoup de questions
qui se font jour sur le traitement des
données sur sa longueur sur le caractère
très floue de l'exposé des motifs
pour quel établissement pour quel type
d'événement les u6 évoqué 1000 milles
personnes sans entrer dans un dans un
détail dans le quartier de la commission
c'est pas pour les actes courants non
pas pour les restaurants pas pour les
cinémas pour les airs il ya besoin de
plus de précisions
qu'est ce que vous attendez encore comme
précise jean bas par exemple que l'on
sache comment s'applique sur le plan
géographique parce que veulent bien que
la situation sanitaire n'est pas la même
d'un bout à l'autre de la france que
l'on sache quelle est la nature des
événements quelle est la nature des
infrastructures tout ça ce n'est pas dit
il ya besoin de précisions qu'ils aient
besoin de skis a besoin de collecter les
données personnelles même anonymisées
non ça me pas certain donc il ya un
débat cet après-midi par comme toujours
nous allons y participer avec diligence
et façon constructive en proposant aussi
des amendements mais c'est pas un nom de
principes sur se passe là ni faire pour
vous écoutez moi je regarde toujours le
point de sortie je ne rentre pas dans
une dans un débat parlementaire surtout
quand on va faire des amendements en
préjugeant de notre de notre
décision d'effectivement vous ferez
précisément sur ce point bas sur les par
exemple sur les données personnelles sur
la nature des établissements voilà et le
recours aux passes sanitaires avaient
l'air pourtant relativement clair il
était question en fait de l'appliquer
pour les rassemblements de plus de 1000
personnes
oui oui mais mille personnes dans un
stade de 80000 c'est pas la même chose
que dans un stade d'enfin dans un
endroit de 5000 c'est pas pareil en
milieu clos et en milieu non que je le
dis parce que la priorité dans des taxis
qui a été proposé au départ et bien que
ces violences que je pense que c'est
nécessaire ce genre de distinction que
l'on que l'on comprenne quoi il s'agit
j'en comprends bien un principe et je
vois bien aussi au plan européen
ce qui se dessine et donc la france à la
nécessité d'être dans ce débat une
dernière chose sur le régime transitoire
de sortie de l'état d'urgence on a bien
compris que vous estimez que c'est une
longue ou trop longue éclipse du débat
démocratique en même temps ce dispositif
là il doit permettre aussi d'activer les
fameux freinage d'urgence dans les
départements où le la maladie
reprendrait en fait est ce que est ce
que c'est pas nécessaire quand même de
garder ce carré collation qui était la
nôtre
au fond la critique en creux je sais que
c'est compliqué c'est que si nous devons
nous habituer à vivre si le régime
ordinaire de la vie c'est vivre avec le
virus
et bien c'est une législation ordinaire
qui doit s'appliquer avec la théorie des
circonstances exceptionnelles qui peut
permettre de prendre des mesures de
freinage c'est ça que nous disons
parions je fais le constat et si je
crois que c'est le président du sénat
qui l'avait chiffré que nous allons plus
légiférer par ordonnances au jour où
nous nous parlons que durant la guerre
d'algérie c'est évidemment un problème
un problème démocratique important voilà
et donc je j'ajoute que cette sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire elle n'est
pas indifférente à la question de la
levée du confinement des seuils de
contamination que le gouvernement s'est
fixé
je m'inquiète un peu du divorce entre le
conseil scientifique et le gouvernement
de ceux de ce point de vue là il n'est
pas indépendant indépendant non plus du
rythme de vaccination et il va y avoir
je crois un effort supplémentaire mais
je regarde ce qui se fait en allemagne
en espagne en italie et je vois que on
vaccine sa marque le jeu prouve que sa
marque le pas et qu' on a besoin
évidemment étaient toutes et tous se
mobiliser ce que je vois dans nos
territoires et vraiment je le rends
hommage et les médecins les infirmiers
les pharmaciens sont très mobilisés
cette crise aussi nasri sanitaires là
des conséquences sociales notamment pour
la jeunesse jeudi dernier l'assemblée
nationale a une nouvelle fois rejetée
votre proposition de loi sur le rsa
porter avec françois ruffin pour la
france insoumise rsa jeunes le
gouvernement lui il défend des aides
plus ciblé deux qui vont vers
l'insertion vers l'accompagnement vers
l'emploi est ce qu'ils n'ont pas raison
mais il faut les deux le problème du
gouvernement c'est que il ya bien avoir
raison tout seul
moi je dis un jeune une solution c'est
très bien tant mieux si on y arrive mais
sauf que je vois plein de jeunes qui
sont sans solution
je vois aussi plein d'étudiants qui en
dépit des dispositifs qui ont été mis en
place continue de grossir les rangs des
banques alimentaires continuent d'être
plus de rendre appartement parce qu'ils
n'ont pas retrouvé leurs petits boulots
qui permet de payer le loyer et donc je
dis c'est là et l'autre
et quand je le regarde le rapport rendu
public par la fage le syndicat étudiant
ce week-end sur la question de savoir si
des dispositifs ont permis de faire
reculer cette misère de la jeunesse le
la réponse est et malheureusement non et
donc il faut faire plus et un minimum
jeunesse ce qui était notre proposition
c'est la proposition portée par françois
ruffin la semaine dernière avec
l'ouverture du rsa
ce minimum jeunesse c'est sortir la tête
de l'eau ne serait ce que dans cette
période de crise
à chaque fois ils étaient proposés à la
majorité que le rsa sous verre
le temps de la crise on sera toujours il
sera toujours loisible de revenir dessus
et de ne pas le prolonger dans votre
dans votre essai un esprit de résistance
maurice valant vous propose également la
création d'un compte personnel
l'activité en disant que c'est ainsi
qu'un des combats qui pourraient
conditionner l'avenir de la gauche
est ce que ces recettes cette formule
que vous proposez ne ressemble pas un
petit peu à ce que ce qu'envisageait le
gouvernement en matière quand il parlait
du dieu du revenu universel d'activité
le rer a qui fit d'abord le rer vous
savez ça fait partie de ces visas sion
ce n'est pas pour la partie de ces
diversions on nous dit vous inquiétez
pas c'est quand on avait proposé
l'expérimentation du revenu de base vous
inquiétez pas il y aura le revenu
universel de l'activité en fait y'a rien
du tout bon bien nous dit
l'accompagnement l'accompagnement on
attend le service publie les
accompagnements il n'arrive pas ce que
je
la réflexion qui est la mienne c'est
nous sommes au coeur d'une révolution
avec des transformations économiques
sociales qui vont être considérables il
faut construire l'industrie de demain
avec les ouvriers d'aujourd'hui il faut
construire l'agriculture de demain avec
les agriculteurs d'aujourd'hui il ne
faut laisser personne au bord du chemin
et donc nous devons avoir un modèle
social qui apprivoise le hasard
aujourd'hui les transitions
professionnelles c'est un saut dans le
vide et on aura probablement beaucoup de
de transition professionnelle il ya
plein de gens qui n'arrivent pas à se
créer des droits par des formes
atypiques d'emploi comment on se
creuserait là qui a une passerelle avec
le f à ce que devait être le rue a en
fait sur le jeu c'est parce que vous
savez moi je parle de choses quand elles
existent pas quand elles sont un slogan
voilà donc je dis ce système là un conte
qui permet de gérer les transitions
professionnelles qui permet de lier
enfin de prendre en compte les temps de
vie sorte de banque des temps et bien
tout ça m'apparaît important apprivoiser
le hasard ne laisser personne au bord de
la route ne pas faire de la transition
environnementale
une aventure catastrophique mais il nous
dit c'est pleinement enthousiasmante
voilà je crois que c'est tout à fait
tout à fait possible c'est ce que l'on
propose évidemment c'est pas se dire on
sait pas ce que le gouvernement propose
on va parler de votre livre mais on va
parler du parti socialiste il ya
quarante ans le 10 mai 1981 françois
mitterrand accédait donc au pouvoir hier
plusieurs socialistes étaient réunis au
creusot il y avait françois hollande y
avait des lunettes jospin y avait ni
l'algo y avait peu olivier faure le
premier secrétaire du ps et ils
défilaient dans les marches pour le
climat pourquoi ce choix bah parce que
la question climatique est une question
importante que le combat du socialisme
il s'est pas arrêté à la conquête du
pouvoir en mai 1981 donc milliards c'est
derrière pour le parti ça veut dire que
le socialisme c'est toujours en voilà et
que l'on regarde évidemment mais 80 non
pas comme une madeleine ou comme une
nostalgie mais comme une source
d'inspiration comme j'allais dire un
souffle françois mitterrand arrive après
23 ans d'opposition
avec cet esprit d'union de la gauche qui
qui porte cette élection eh bien nous on
travaille vous avez un retour de la
question sociale qui est d'une extrême
violence vous avez évoqué la question
des jeunes mais il y a dix millions de
pauvres
il y à une crise qui ne qui n'en finit
pas et qui inquiète aujourd'hui
les dispositifs qui est heureusement
qu'ils sont là viennent en soutien des
entreprises qu'en sera-t-il demain je
vois beaucoup d'entrepreneurs qui me
disent ne rêverait pas à rembourser le
pge bien cette question sociale
elle n'est pas derrière nous elle est
devant nous et mai 81
cette publicité certes confiance au fond
dans l'avenir ce refus de la résignation
ben je crois que c'est ce qui doit nous
animer et ce qui doit nous animer font
moins c'est ce que j'appelle cette geste
c'est quand on dit changer la vie bah
oui je crois que depuis 40 ans les
socialistes ont un peu changé quand même
il aura quand même une soirée ce soir en
direct du siège du parti socialiste bien
sûr bien sûr réveillon l'espoir vous y
participerez vous bien sûr alors j'ai
quelques contraintes familiales qui fait
que je n'y serai pas mais j'ai été
évidemment sollicité j'ai fait
participer à unis à une émission
rétrospective à jarnac le plus jarnac où
j'étais très très heureux de visiter la
maison natale de françois mitterrand
voilà bien sûr que tout cela fait partie
de notre patrimoine qu' on ne veut pas
considérer que le socialisme est une
idée qui appartient au passé
moi je crois que c'est une idée radicale
mandat avait quand je regarde ce qui se
passe aux etats unis
je me dis qu'il ya quelques espoirs un
mot sur l'union puisque vous parlez de
l'union la gauche en 80 elle était
plutôt divisée d'ailleurs l'union s'est
faite au second tour derrière françois
mitterrand qui était arrivé très
aujourd'hui si on regarde les sondages
le ps est extrêmement loin des scores de
françois mitterrand olivier faure lui
les partisans d'une union à gauche sauf
que vous avez fabien roussel qui est
candidat à la présidentielle jean luc
mélenchon qui est candidat à la
présidentielle les écologistes ils
disent le plan a c'est un candidat écolo
n'y a pas de plan b est ce que
finalement vous n'êtes pas les seuls à
être prêts à vous effacez et pourquoi
mais écoutez d'abord il faut chaud ce
week end puisque ont évoqué françois
mitterrand qui disait qu'il fallait être
unitaire pour deux que sur les trois
élections auxquelles il était candidat
je crois que deux fois il était le
candidat unique de la gauche et ses les
deux fois où il a perdu et
oui mais vous savez les circonstances
n'étaient pas les mêmes
et à chaque fois il a progressé jusqu'à
jusqu'à la victoire donc il faut de la
détermination
moi je suis pour que l'on travaille à
cette union dans l'affirmation de ce que
chacun ait et moi je suis socialiste je
pense que la question sociale est
central que même la question
environnementale est un levier puissant
de transformation sociale d'amélioration
de la condition humaine
pour moi l'écologie c'est l'écologie est
vulnérable ce que je dis dans ce livre
l'écologie des inégalités celle qui
dessert d'une certaine manière la
ceinture pour tous ceux qui souffrent
mieux se loger mieux se nourrir mieux se
déplacer songez à la question de la des
passoires énergétiques bas ce sont
beaucoup de gens modestes qui vivent
aussi mal qu ils se chauffent mal et
donc rien de ce qui concerne la question
environnementale est indifférent aux
socialistes parce que c'est une des
conditions de réalisation des objectifs
de justice et d'égalité et bien nous
sommes équipés pour affronter ça et
c'est ce que nous disons ce que je dis à
travers ce livre ce que nous disons au
parti socialiste à travers le projet à
travers les rendez vous tous les mois
que nous donnons à celles et ceux qui
veulent savoir ce que nous proposons est
derrière vous êtes équipé votre avis
votre projet mais ce qui vous y croyez
vraiment encore ce que c'est moi j'y
crois toujours
vous savez je fais partie de ceux qui
sont rentrés au parti socialiste comme
tout le monde on partage beaucoup ans
partait voilà je suis élu député pour la
première fois mais ce que je dis c'est
parlons un peu moins de nous et parlons
des gens il ya beaucoup de gens moi je
les reçois dans ma permanence condé vie
dure
jeudi c'est un peu tautologique des
visas invivable qui veut punir de leur
métier qu'ils veulent être très
correctement rémunérés et c'est possible
qu'ils veulent ne pas être cassée par
leur travail
les différences d'espérance de vie ça
c'est un combat pour nous ben oui il
faut dire qu'on peut se retrousser les
manches tous ensemble et qu'on a
beaucoup de raisons de mieux vivre
ensemble et moins d'inégalités
en réalité c'est bon pour tout le monde
et dans votre livre vous parlez des gens
et de votre modèle de société en esprit
de résistance chez flammarion merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin merci stéphane à demain
[Musique]